محمود ماذا يعني اسقاط طائره سكايلارك 2
بالنسبه للمقاومه سكايلارك 2 هي طائره
بدون طيار تستخدمها قوات المشا لعمليات
الاستطلاع وعمليات التجسس وما يسمى
بالاستحواذ على الهدف ويمكن ان تصوب
الليزر لمساعده الطائرات الاخرى الان هذه
الطائرات عند اسقاطها ماذا يعني ذلك
بالنسبه للطرف المدافع اولا هذا يعني ان
الطرف المدافع طور اسلحه الدفاع الجوي
سواء الحركيه او غير الحركيه ماذا نعني
بالاسلحه الحركيه هي مثل مضادات الطيران
كالصواريخ والاسلحه
الرشاشه غير حركيه هي اجهزه التشويش
الالكتروني على سبيل المثال قد يكون قد تم
هذا الاسقاط بالتشويش الالكتروني او
بالاسلحه الحركيه اذا كان بالتشويش
الالكتروني فيمكن انزال الجزء الاكبر من
الطائره بدون ان يكون هناك ضرر كبير في
الجسم الان هذا يقودنا الى الشق الثاني
عاده ما تستخدم الاطراف الحروب لتطوير
التكنولوجيا والتكتيكات واساليب القتال
الى اخره فبالتالي يمكن للطرف المدافع
الاستفاده مما يسمى بالهندسه العكسيه وهو
تفكيك الاجزاء معرفه كيف تعمل مع بعضها
البعض ما هي الترددات الى اخره لتجهيز
تكنولوجيا متطوره او اكثر تطورا بالنسبه
له في المستقبل